bonjour claude aujourd'hui devant un
jury je voudrais un grand verre des
citronnade s'il te plaît ah oui mais
alors si j'arrive à trouver la bouteille
parce que j'ai mis de l'ordre ce matin
et je me retrouve plus du tout du tout
merci à 60 centimes 60 centimes en
baisse encore augmenté mais si tu crois
que c'est moi tu remontes pour le
plaisir tu te trouves tu n'as pas lu
dans les journaux ce qui s'est passé à
la dernière réunion des pays producteurs
de citrouilles bon tu met en colère je
sais bien que tu n'es pas responsable
tel impôt d'accor les taxes nous enfin
julie je te faisais cas aucun reproche
dessus c'est bien moi mais oui je le
promets à l'est soit plus fâché bas à
l'aller finie la lah et ben dis-donc
tout ton histoire m'a donné faim
j'ai envie de manger quelque chose de
très bon tu veux manger du chocolat non
des bombes aussi trop à la mode alors
ans non j'ai envie de quelque chose de
très très très bon une tarte aux pommes
bien aux biens à mille feuilles mais moi
si c'était moi qui choisis ça je
prendrai une crosse priant sans oublier
des éclairs au chocolat et une meringue
à la crème chantilly
ça vous plairait à mon goût des comme ça
oui et vous si il en cuisine je n'avais
pas entendu arriver mais j'étais ému je
voudrais vous demander une faveur mais
avec plaisir l'asie voilà je voudrais
vous inviter à un très bon goûter
oui et qui va le préparer moi mail à toi
même - et alors et bien non juste une
question comme ça bompard alors vous
êtes d'accord
bah c'est à dire que oui la libye a
accepté avec joie avec joie bon alors je
me dépêche
jb g je suis content de vous inviter à
ne vraiment pas gentil d'avoir eu l'air
d'hésiter au bout tu es drôle pas non
non mais tu t'imagines en train de
manger une une glace aux anchois ou ou
un gloubi boulga avec de la saucisse et
du chocolat ou encore une murène
chantilly avec de labutta oulalalala
c'est vrai j'avais oublié oui d'autant
plus que moi j'étais prête à craquer
et moi aussi et si on mange que casimir
nous apporte on est sûr d'être tous
malades voilà qu'est ce qu'on va faire
écoute j'ai dû pas ici si on mange ça
avec du chocolat
comme ça on pourra plus fin et on pourra
faire semblant de toucher à tout
très bonne idée claudine ariel voulez du
pain et du chocolat vous préférez
attendre le retour de casimir et manger
ce qui va porter et vous olivier
frédéric et les autres du pain et du
chocolat ou le goûter de casimir le
bouter de qom où les cas on attend aux
dragons flore et la faune et la flore et
la faune ailée qui sont aujourd'hui un
petit peu de son nom ne vous dit à une
femme
[Musique]
voilà et voilà c'est price
ces chocolats pas ce chocolat était
vraiment très bon mais je crois que j'ai
trop manger pour moi aussi je serais
incapable d'avaler quoi que ce soit
d'autre
bon ben voilà julie françois muriel
claude tous les enfants rené vite le
goûter ont servi à nosy julie du coup
nous nous voici casimir a dit tu nous as
rien préparé
c'est une surprise tout est dans la
malle magique car c'est encore plus
inquiétant que je ne pensais
attention
au hezbollah alors il y a des tartes aux
pommes des éclairs de ce club des mille
familles foule débrayage woosh des
meringues là ces chantiers
tout ce dont nous avions envie de patch
casimir
nous avons douté de toi nous sommes bien
punis nous sommes vraiment des idiots